every Thursday in our series a more
perfect union we aim to show that what
unites us as Americans is greater than
what divides us remember that well this
morning we take you to the streets of
Medford Massachusetts and that's where a
plan to improve driver safety with this
optical illusion could potentially save
countless lives
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn introduces us to the
ten-year-old behind the idea drivers on
the road can often be dangerously
distracted I've seen people just speed
pass stop signs speed pass crosswalks
and people are like could get really
injured so ten-year-old ISA and her
classmate Erik came up with a plan just
outside their school that would make
drivers look twice is an illusion
painted on the ground to look like
actual object the idea came from a close
call
Erik's brother had when he was crossing
the street and through their research
they found illusions like these are a
worldwide trend 3d crosswalks are
popping up in places like Iceland
Germany and Beijing it comes at a time
the number of accidents in the u.s.
involving pedestrians is rising in 2017
more than 190 3,000 pedestrians were
injured in crashes they were really
concerned about safety for their fellow
students the fourth graders turned to
Medford Mayor Stephanie Burke who now
hopes to take the idea to every school
in the district books don't teach her
this civic engagement is something that
you just you see happen you see success
and then you try to emulate it and do
more Issa is part of the Center for
citizenship and social responsibility an
organization that encourages young
people to get involved in the community
mike coates is an advisor for the center
this is a great example of them sticking
to an idea and going through all the
steps and talking in this case to all
the adults and the powers that be while
it took a year to get the green light
Issa is hoping to get these 3d walkways
on the roads everywhere
go ISA yeah something tells me it would
work but it is interesting how a little
kid can see something and say I can do
something about that yes and then it
just requires listening adult oh you
don't ease get those yeah
let the children leave yeah